chaotic bottoms says North has such
great style where is she pulling her
pieces from I never thought that at 10
years old my daughter would already be
stealing my clothes she really has the
best style and she loves to go vintage
shopping she pulls a lot from my closet
and from her dad's closet I didn't pull
anything from my mom's closet actually
but what Courtney and I did this is so
mean she walked in once and we were like
putting our names on her shoes and she's
like what are you guys doing and we're
like well when you die we'll know like
who gets what she was like 30 but it's
crazy that North gets it so young and
just picks out the coolest stuff that I
have